hi I'd like to welcome you to the
September disaster information
specializations webinar planning for
disaster partnerships ensure continuity
of operations it seems appropriate to
have this webinar this month which is
National Preparedness month and before
we head into the webinar I'm going to
have Stacey artisan our branch chief
here at the National Library of Medicine
disaster information management Research
Center chance to give an update on what
we've been up to in the last several
weeks so I had Stacey Thank You
Siobhan's but I just wanted to say that
our thoughts are with the people of
North and South Carolina and Virginia
who are now recovering from the
devastating effects of hurricane and
tropical storm Florence we know that
this will be a difficult time for many
people who have lost so much NLM and our
partner Regional Medical Library in the
southeast Atlantic region or SCA are
trying to ensure that the public as well
as health care providers and emergency
responders have access to high-quality
health information the SCA is
maintaining a page with a number of
links to health information resources
for hurricanes and floods and here at
NLM in our disaster information
management research center Jim Erick
we're sending out emails and tweets with
authoritative links to information over
the last several days we have sent
information concerning the environmental
health effects as we transition sort of
from the response to the recovery phase
including information on mold and debris
cleanup from sources such as the
National Institute of Environmental
Health Sciences a partner NIH Institute
and the Environmental Protection Agency
as well as information on coal ash
carbon monoxide and livestock waste
management as I'm sure many of you have
heard about the pig farm lagoons so we
have links to some of our resources from
the from toxnet and
from pubmed jen is now adding in some of
these links to our chat box so please
take a look in there so that you can
find this information if you're not
already on our listserv and have
received them we'll continue to monitor
the situation and send updates as needed
derek has also had the opportunity to
share this information with numerous
NGOs nongovernmental organizations and
federal agencies we're working on the
crowdsourcing of social media efforts
although they are listening and
monitoring social media they also have
the opportunity to share health
information with their constituencies
many of them are people going back to
their homes to their businesses to do
the cleanup Denmark is also working with
the National Institute of Environmental
Health Sciences on the NIH disaster
research response program or dr2 and
looking into ways in which NIH can
assist the states in conducting health
research to ensure the safety and
follow-up of workers and the public in
cleaning up after the damage so please
take a look at some of these links and
if you have people that you need to
share them with feel free to share this
information we're also sending out
tweets a to monitor our at an alumni
Merrik account for more information and
more links to information and now I'll
turn it back over to you Siobhan all
right thanks Stacey so I'm going to move
along here this as I said this is
National Preparedness month and FEMA
does a lot of work and coming up with
themes for each week and for this week
the theme is check your coverage and
they're talking about of course your
insurance what do you what are you have
to cover your losses like if he was
talking about so many people have
devastating losses from from this
hurricane this is also the one year
anniversary from Hurricane Maria we saw
things happening in the hurricane in
Hawaii the wildfires you know the list
goes on so what kind of coverage do you
have and we are talking about the kind
of coverage that you have to keep your
institution going so we're going to
be talking today about what's known as
coop the continuity of operations plan
and about ways to set up memorandum of
understanding those kinds of things with
other agencies we're going to be talking
a little bit about and
a MoU that we have with some local
libraries here in the Bethesda area we
have some tips to help you write up your
own plans we have a guest speaker and
Holmen who is going who's going to
provide information from the perspective
of a military librarian we'll give you a
little overview of how successful our
MOU has been in some links to some other
information that you can turn to if
you're interested in doing this so we
want to make sure that you're covered if
you're if you have been in a library
that whether it was a one of these
larger events that we've been talking
about or a local event that shut your
library down for a little while could
you enter into the chat box just a few
words on what that experience is like
for you we all you know we we think
about this kind of event and oh my gosh
what what what am I going to do now my
library just lost power and we we think
about those things when we have huge
events like the Hurricanes and the
wildfires but one recently in northern
Massachusetts the gas lines it started
exploding that's a local event for that
community and just as important for them
to think about what do I do if if my
library is involved in a local event so
if you want to share that with us that
would be great
so what is continuity of operations
there there are just plans that you set
up with someone else
to make sure or with yourself to make
sure that if your library or your agency
your public health department's
emergency management agency for whatever
reason flooding loss of power
shut down and you want to be able to get
back up into operation within 12 hours
and be able to remain operating for up
to 30 days so we call that coop and
hopefully a lot of you already have two
plans and if you don't we're going to be
giving you some ideas on how you can get
some of those plans in place so the tube
is actually has arisen on a federal
level from the US presidential policy
directive 40 and it orders FEMA the
Federal Emergency Management Agency to
coordinate continuity programs in
executive departments to ensure that
agencies can continue to perform
essential functions so that's pretty
important and here are some of the
elements that fall in this specific
presidential preparedness directive and
if you look at the list these are the
kinds of things that you want to make
sure if your library sets down how do
you let people who worked in your
library even know don't bother coming to
work today or yes you have to work but
here is where you're going to work and
how you're going to work or they already
know what to do you don't have to tell
them anything they just automatically go
and start carrying out the coop plan so
it's a long list of components that you
would want to put maybe not all of them
go in your coop but these are things to
consider in to think about does it
belong in your tube and there's a lot of
resources that can help you simplify
this process once you the first time you
set up a coop it might take a little bit
of time but once you do it keeping it up
to date and maintaining it is a pretty
simple process so down at the bottom of
this page I have a link to the FEMA
guidance directive if you're interested
in looking at
this this directive in greater detail
there's a couple of directives in
community risk assessments as well that
FEMA has published so just a little bit
of if you're interested in more and I
think Jen yeah Jen just put that in the
chat box thanks Jen
so
in the in the process of this
presentation we are going to be talking
about creating a continuity of course
services and we're a federal library how
do we set up this kind of continuity of
operations planning and cooperating with
other agencies as the federal library
and what we found is that that that that
hasn't been a problem for us so when you
when you start to think about how your
core core services are going to be
needed by a community Robin is going to
go into greater detail about this but we
have two military hospitals within our
region and if something happened to one
of them how how would one of the
libraries there how would the health
care providers who supports that they
support still have access to information
and it's really important that that
library has a plan to continue to
operate during a disaster so we have a
memorandum of understanding they are
also sometimes called mutual aid
agreements and these allow agencies to
establish collaborations with other
agencies and partners to increase the
resources available to support both
disaster and public health emergency
responses the documents can be binding
or non-binding and that I think is kind
of something to keep in mind that's
really important for our mo use their
non-binding
it means that we have this informal
agreement with each other that this is
what we're going to do and we're going
to support each other but their
non-binding and and that's that actually
helps us to be able to collaborate on a
on a less formal level but one that we
know we can we only commit to things
that we know we can carry out in that
process so I'm going to turn it over to
rob and who's going to talk about
so that says duh MOU thank you Siobhan
all right for the next part of our
presentation I'm going to describe an
actual partnership as Siobhan mentioned
that the National Library of Medicine
has participated in for many years and
in fact this year I just realized is our
10-year anniversary in 2008 the National
Library of Medicine was a founding
member of the Bethesda medical libraries
emergency preparedness partnership along
with several other area medical
libraries known affectionately as the
Lemp so since 2008 we have added a
couple members and unfortunately lost
one as you can see all the current
members are government and military
libraries including us at the National
Library of Medicine the uniformed
services University of the Health
Sciences the National Institutes of
Health library the Walter Reed National
Military Medical Center medical library
and the Fort Belvoir Community Hospital
medical library Suburban Hospital
library left the partnership in 2010
because they no longer had a librarian
sadly so why do we do this why would
this partnership form ten years ago
slide lists for bullets that I'm going
to explain a little more about each in
detail so the first identify issues and
challenges that may confront our region
in the event of a disaster
so that means thinking about what are
the most likely types of events and here
in the mid-atlantic we're not likely to
have an earthquake or a large one anyway
and we don't have frequent tornadoes or
sometimes affected violence Atlantic
hurricanes sometimes heavy rain from
those local flooding and of course being
so close to Washington DC we
unfortunately have to keep in mind the
possibility of a nuclear radiation
emergency as well so wherever you are
listening to this the first step would
be to think about what kinds of
disasters are likely to happen in your
area
second point assemble resources that can
be used to aid our respective
institutions and the region in the event
of a disaster so note that this bullet
point actually contains two goals first
of all we in the partnership intend to
each other in the event of a disaster
and later I'll go into more detail about
exactly what that means for us but
secondly because libraries serve their
communities we intend to keep providing
that service if at all possible and this
is especially in the case of a disaster
when medical information could be
critical to the medical response the
third bullet create policies and
procedures for mutual assistance and
support that shall enable the continued
or expanded provision of medical
information this is where the detailed
planning is essential so that if the
moment comes that this partnership is
actually activated you don't have to sit
down and have an extended discussion
about what you can provide and will
provide in terms of mutual assistance
you've already figured that out and
formally agreed on it or sort of
informally I guess in our case but all
you have to do is follow the procedure
that you've already established and
lastly provide feedback and guidance to
other regional Everett library
partnerships based upon our experiences
so I I can't speak for others
individually personally I've not
provided guidance to any particular
partnership but Siobhan and I did give
this talk once before or a similar
version of this talk to a subgroup that
they of the special Library Association
and and maybe some librarians from there
decided to go on and form their own
partnerships after learning about our
experience we would certainly encourage
that and if you have any questions or
comments later well during the talk you
can put them in the webinar chat box or
our contact information will be on the
last slide so don't hesitate to reach
out with questions so next I can click
this slide there we are we'll talk about
the paperwork involved and happily there
is very little paperwork here at NLM we
have a folder on our shared drive for
the partnership and just subfolders for
each year and in each subfolder there
are just three documents there's an
agenda for each year's meeting that we
hold a contact list with work and
personal contact info this includes not
just phone numbers but home addresses so
we have a sense of where people are in
the area and we even have a column
indicating whether or not somebody has a
personal car at their disposal and
lastly we have the current version for
that year of the memorandum
Understanding or MOU now I'm gonna share
my screen and we'll take a look at the
actual MOU bear with me for a moment I
switch and pull up all right hopefully
you can see the MOU here in the
beginning this talks about the libraries
that are involved I've already talked
about that and the purpose which we've
already discussed as well on the front
page you can see that each years whose
the formation of this partnership we've
met and formally approved it here's
where the MOU actually begins
but discusses what the purpose is in
greater detail and why it's a useful
thing to do it talks about when this
plan is intended to be implemented and
it notes as Siobhan was discussing
earlier our agreement is informal and
flexible and non-binding so we have more
detailed definition here of a disaster
this is a good idea to discuss if if you
do have a partnership what exactly is
going to activate the partnership that
you're building we have a lot listed
here but it's essential to think that
through before it happens after that if
the partnership does get activated
there's a section here called method of
cooperation that discusses how we would
actually go about activating and
contacting each other and there's a
point of contact which starts with the
National Library of Medicine and goes on
to the other partner libraries as well
I'm going through here pretty quickly
but there's a there's a very detailed
section at the end that I want to get to
and show you so here's a overview of
services that might be offered and
services that would not be offered in
terms of mutual aid or assistance and
cost recovery in our agreement it's
quite simple it will not be reimbursed
the authorization here's where it gets
very details so this here is our chart
explaining exactly which resources in
great detail we would be offering or
might be needed in case of a disaster
talking about communications databases
staffing
collections the physical space and so on
backup power this is probably the
hardest part of planning going through
this in great detail and thinking about
what you really would need what would be
essential to your operations in these
circumstances and because we have some
military libraries involved we also have
notes on what happens if a lockdown is
implemented and who can get access to
what exactly during that time because
probably unlikely and we'll go with it
this I think a little bit later but it's
unlikely that anybody not from the
medical the military medical library
would be able to get onto the physical
campus in case of an emergency like that
okay when to stop sharing this screen go
back to our slides here so once again to
be very clear this Memorandum of
Understanding is informal and flexible
it's non-binding and voluntary and it's
for guidance only but that's that the
guidance that the not the MOU provides
along with our partners voluntary
willingness to provide mutual aid in the
event of a disaster that can make a real
difference in our library's continuity
of operations should it ever be
activated so here are a few tips from
our experience it's really it might be
much more simple than you than you would
think we have an annual meeting each
fall I set the date and ask for a
volunteer to host and ask for any
contact information updates about a week
before the meeting I distribute the
current MOU and the very brief agenda at
the meeting itself we read through the
MOU section by section we actually do
that through line by line and make sure
that nothing's changed if it has I
marked those changes on the paper those
numbers we have things small items to
follow up with after the fact and then
we make it a point to go out to lunch
and enjoy each other socially as well
because sometimes some of us only see
each other once a year after the meeting
I update the document with the changes
we've discussed redistributed and the
reason should be any updated
TEKT info to the group when I do that I
remind everybody to first of all put it
in a shared accessible location on their
network the electronic file but also
remind everybody to print out a copy and
also keep that in an accessible location
because it's likely in the event of a
severe disaster that you might not have
power to your facility and you would not
be able to access your electronic files
but you would want those phone numbers
of your partners in that scenario and
then I need nothing for the next ten
months as long as there's no emergency
which so far so far so good okay so if
this is an idea that you're interested
in there are some questions you should
start asking yourself and as I mentioned
already when I showed our MoU the
hardest part is at the beginning
hammering out those details about what
your what services could be affected
what impact that would have on your
users and what you could provide or
would need in terms of mutual aid for
how long were your services be
unavailable if they did go offline and
in the disaster would your users require
more or less or the same information in
a medical library scenario very possibly
more if there's a disaster that people
are trying to respond to if you're a
different kind of library potentially
less so you need to identify that for
yourself so these are a few questions on
the slide for more information the
National Association of city and County
health officials has a document called
orbs are a toolkit rather called the
administrative preparedness legal
guidebook it's for health departments
for them to partner with community
organizations or neighboring
jurisdictions but the principle is the
same to gain access to shareable unused
resources and in the toolkit they
discuss how mutual aid agreements and
memoranda of understanding can allow
collaborations with other organizations
and support public health emergency
response they can be binding or
non-binding just for quick resource
identification and procurement so in our
resources supplies at the end we will we
have a link to that toolkit which may be
of interest to you they suggest that you
walk through it they have a
decision-making
to assess your own organization and then
potential partnership ideas okay and
with that I am now going to introduce
our guest speaker and Holmen and Holmen
had been at the Walter Reed National
Military Medical Center darnell medical
library since 2012 before that she was
at the National Naval Medical Center the
ER State Library she's been a member of
month since 2012 and the second time
that we've called upon her to give a
unique perspective of military libraries
and partnerships such as these I've put
up a bolt with a few points but I'm
gonna go with them
Clemson's actually I'm going to begin
with a horrible confession that only
occurred to me while you guys were
speaking we had a power outage for like
a week in the spring and I never told
anybody I just kind of thought I should
have told them but but what we really
focus on is madhva pens on the crisis
that that you're having in the case of
the power outage we had access to our
electronic resources and so we didn't
have to rely on anybody in the
partnership but at the same time from a
communications perspective I'm feeling
horribly guilty I did want to touch a
little bit on the geography just because
I think it's so interesting if you look
at where NLM NIH Walter Reed and and
even Suburban Hospital are there like
right next to each other like I was
going to walk to Suburban Hospital the
other day and I would have walked across
the NIH campus to get there so it made
it makes sense from a partnership
perspective so that if something
horrible happens you know we could get
to each other's campuses so first of all
so why is Fort Belvoir involved they are
not within walking distance
they are outside the beltway and the
reason behind that is as you saw we
changed from being the National Naval
Medical Center to the Walter Reed
National Military Medical Center and
part of that is we became partners with
Fort Belvoir in the National Capital
Region so kind of lets you know how
flexible and and how our memory our MOU
is a living document we were like well
here's Fort Belvoir what what do we do
do we have them join us do we just keep
them out and we realized that having a
little bit of redundancy outside of the
Beltway would be a beneficial thing so
so we embraced them and and have not had
to tap into their butyl beautiful
services when I first started being
involved with um with the bem what
sebelum we talked a lot about and it
will be good for you to be familiar with
where these libraries are so that we can
go to the other buildings in a crisis
and and at first light that we talked
have such a cool idea and and certainly
as information sharers we would we would
do that and then the security
requirements changed on our base at
first there was a list and and if we put
all of the members on the list they
theoretically should have been able to
get in in a crisis and then the security
requirements changed and I was told that
if people filled out paperwork and
honestly I forget if it was once a year
or once every six months
and this was like hardcore Navy
paperwork then then then they could come
to our security building and wait for an
hour to be cleared and then maybe be led
on the base and at that point we
realized it would just be easier for us
to walk to the gate and escort them on
the base and that's why
in in MoU you see base escort required
because if another library is closed and
somebody has to use our library it
really is going to be easier just to
walk out and get them I want someone to
mention in our library as and most we
have kind of a dual focus as far as
disaster preparedness and response we
have a huge reliance on our electronic
collection when our power was out for
the week we're in we're in a fine
historical building that was dedicated
by President Roosevelt in 1942 and it
loses power
if the basement gets wet which is what
happened for a week so we actually just
went over to another building went to a
computer training room and and ran the
library our clinical librarians still
went on rounds because their buildings
had power it was just the building that
the library with him and so the the
electronic resources are incredibly
helpful at the same time we are a DoD
library and well I felt like I'm going
to talk smack about DoD and address I'm
not
sometimes there sometimes we all have
internet access problems let's say that
sometimes we have DoD firewall issues of
we weren't able to access our wylie
content for like two months last winter
so so things happen and so I kind of
have two scenarios that I plan for one
is we don't have internet access or
electricity or whatever we need and and
this is my zombie attack scenario and in
that case I want a core collection a
corpse print collection that people
could run to
if they need to do things in in what I
consider to be like the worst case
scenario but then the other is to to
make sure that we've got our robust Irie
source collection and since so much of
its bender hosted that helps a lot as
far as it being redundant but it also
means that I'm like obsessed with having
a cellular plan on my iPad in case we do
have internet problems and those I think
are the two main scenarios internet
works or Internet doesn't work and yes
yes we say so far no we haven't had this
summon we haven't had to activate the
Avengers but uh but we're we're ready
and and I do feel like the fact that
we're engaging as a group has benefits
beyond what we're you know beyond the
preparedness aspect I think that was
everything we had to tell you thank you
I absolutely agree I mean obviously any
emergency plan is one that you hope to
never have to activate but you are ready
if you need to and I totally agree
that's the partnership that you build
while doing an emergency partnership
it's also the relationships as well
which can benefit you in many ways not
just in an emergency so thank you and
pass it back to chiffon
all right yeah my phone hung up on me so
I'm sorry about that can you hear me now
yes we can hear you fine thank you okay
I don't know what my phone just suddenly
hung up on me so I hope it didn't happen
to other people
so are you turning it on over to me I
did already okay all right sorry about
that technology so so Robin and Anne
thank you so much those were that was
such a great description of the work
that we've done with our MOU and we have
not had to activate it we've been very
lucky but as Ann said it's more than
just having the ability to say all right
the power's out and the computer room is
down and I can't do it
the fact that we get together once a
year and just talk to each other about
what's going on in the libraries and
stay up to date you know that's a
benefit of of all of these plans getting
to know about different kinds of
libraries and organizations and what
kinds of information they need that's
always a really helpful part of the
process even if you never activate it
which we hope you never do so we've
improved our planning we've improved our
planning not just for us for the MOU but
for those are individual libraries as
well and we hope that we serve as a
model for other library communities what
I one of the things that we haven't
talked a lot about Stacey referred to
the national network of libraries of
medicine the southeast Atlantic region
all of you are members of a national
network of libraries of Medicine region
and each of them can provide you with
assistance also in locating libraries
and organizations in your community that
might be interested in partnering with
you I want to show you let's see if this
works
the emergency preparedness response
section of the national network of
libraries of medicine pacific south
region and they recently were doing a
lot in response to hurricane lane in
hawaii so as you can see there is a
direct contact person at the southeast
Atlantic region so you can just reach
out to them that section Tech's might be
a first step for you to say you know
this is what's happened in my library
and can you help
they have phone numbers listed for you
on the left-hand side to tell you who
you can contact
helping you make develop disaster plan
identifying a backup library one of the
things that we've been excited about a
way a personal goes to their state and
emergency so if you so they provide you
with state specific information so if
you're looking to find out if you're in
Arizona who do I contact and who's the
Arizona Division of Emergency Management
they have that contact information right
here in their libguide but the thing
that we've been most excited about is
here on these other tabs our pages are
syndicated you can just go ahead and do
exactly what they've done they've
created a hurricane resource page by
simply getting the code from our health
information guide on hurricanes it looks
so nice and if they wanted to they could
put information above this line that's
local so if you want to syndicate a page
you can do the same thing you can
syndicate it within a libguide and then
add local information as well so the NLM
is a really important resource when
you're talking about creating these
types of continuity of operations plans
and you can take a look at this regional
map if you're not already one it if your
library isn't already a member or your
organization it's not just for libraries
and
go ahead and click on the region that
covers your map and find out how to
become a member so we're really excited
about what the what the PSR has done in
their live guide and what the other
regions have done in terms of emergency
preparedness and response and helping
other libraries create these kinds of
cooperative plans we also have on
disaster lit our database of grey
literature we have a search and then if
you could put the link to that search
thank you you can read my mind can't you
Jen I'm going to go ahead and share that
as well I should've just stayed on the
screen
so within our database
I think it's their version of that
you
within our database we have examples of
continuity of operation plans and
guidelines on how to create one so
there's a lot of information here to
help you in developing to plan yourself
so what we hope is that you continue to
attend our webinars that you go take a
look at all of this information that you
create
a coop plans for your library or
organizations that like us you never
have to activate and if you have any
questions please feel free to contact
either Robin and RI and we're happy to
help you
with any of the
with any of the coop planning that you
might want to undertake so are there any
questions
and while I anticipate that you are
typing in questions if you're interested
in earning an MLA C e credit first fill
out the survey
answer the questions on that survey and
then you have to log into the Medical
Library Association website click on my
learning and enter this code and it will
provide a link to
these certificates that one MLA ce4 this
this specific webinar
so Robin are and you have any last words
of advice to provide anyone
I think it's been a pretty good process
for us pretty simple to do and very
worthwhile yeah I would agree with
everything you just said I don't think I
have any further comments yeah we were
debating if we make cookies for the 10th
anniversary but that's not really
relevant to the part of the listeners I
think it is see the benefits that you
can get whether it's always food sharing
that's a we should put that on the mou
right and again many institutions have
coop plans but they may not get down
quite to the level of the of the library
or consider the unique considerations of
the library that could be different to
than a clinical aspect or a research
aspect so it's always a good idea to
take what your institution might might
have done and then expand on it to
ensure that the libraries needs are are
met and actually that is another one of
the hidden benefits is the library has
visibility with the hospital's emergency
planning team you know mainly because I
called them every year and I say just to
remind you we are on this thing it's
associated with the thing that you are
on and and are the point of contact
still the same and I'm still your planet
point of contact and and now this
wonderful emergency planning person who
I don't think I'd ever normally get to
meet you know she and I see each other
we recognize each other and and so
hopefully if there was a real disaster
it would make the light bulb go off and
go oh the library has resources and can
help us so that kind of engagement is
helpful okay well seeing no questions I
will end early and thank everyone for
attending the call this month and state
you know join us next month again we'll
be having another webinar in October so
thanks so much and sign up for our
listserv if you haven't already thank
you everyone